هذا أيضًا أمر رائع بالنسبة لي ، لذا كشف
مدير الطب الرياضي بولاية بنسلفانيا
مؤخرًا أن 30 إلى 35 في المائة
من الرياضيين العشرة الكبار الذين تم طلبهم
يبدو أنهم أصيبوا أيضًا بالتهاب
في القلب ، ما يحدث هناك
هذا أمر مخيف جدًا
كما تعلمون  وهذا
شيء سمعناه
أه نوع من اللمحات لقد رأيت لمحات
من آه خلال الأسابيع العديدة الماضية
أم نعتقد أنك تعرف ويمكننا عرض
صورة لما يحدث على وجه التحديد
في القلب هنا
كان هذا نوعًا من الفحص  كان هناك
بعض القلق من أن هؤلاء الرياضيين
كانوا يطورون عضلة
القلب عضلة القلب والتي هي في الأساس
التهاب
في عضلة القلب الآن الكثير من هؤلاء
الأشخاص وعلى
الأقل في البداية لا يبدو أن لديهم
الكثير من الأعراض وقد تم
العثور على هذا بالمصادفة
ولكن كجزء من  بالعودة إلى الرياضة ، بدأت العديد من
الجامعات في
إجراء فحوصات القلب
على هؤلاء اللاعبين ، وكما أشرت فإن
حوالي 35
بالمائة لديهم دليل على الالتهاب.  نشوئ
عضلة القلب
الآن أنت تعرف بالضبط ما يعنيه هذا بالضبط
نعتقد أنه بسبب الالتهاب
المنتشر في الجسم بسبب
الكوفيد
ولكن ماذا يعني ذلك بالنسبة لهؤلاء
اللاعبين ، أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، ليس
الرياضيون
فقط هم من يطورون هذا الآخر.  يقوم
الناس بتطويره أيضًا ولكن في
الرياضيين الذين يعملون على مستوى عالٍ
من الوظائف ، يمكن لبعض الالتهابات المماثلة
في القلب أن تقلل
من قدرتهم على اللعب أو قدرتهم
على اللعب على نفس المستوى ،
وهذا ما يسبب القلق
ولهذا السبب.  مثل كيفن وارين ،
مفوض العشرة الكبار ،
قال بشكل أساسي أنك تعرف أن الوقت المستقطع
سنبطئ الموسم الذي تعرفه ،
ونؤجل بداية الموسم
حتى نكتشف ذلك ونتأكد من
أنه يمكننا فحص هؤلاء اللاعبين
لتحديد ما إذا كان لديهم هذا
التهاب القلب ومعرفة ما يجب
فعله حيال
ذلك فقط للتأكد من أنني أفهم أن
هذا الشيء أكثر انتشارًا
مما يمكنك قوله بين الرياضيين
أنا لا أعتقد ذلك ، لا أعتقد أن الأمر يتعلق
فقط برؤية هذا أكثر في الرياضيين
لأن هناك الآن برامج حيث
يقومون بفحص لاعبي الكلية
لأنهم يفكرون في إعادتهم
للعب ، أعني أن الكثير من هؤلاء اللاعبين
أفهمهم  هو من التحدث إلى
بعض الأطباء الذين أشرفوا على
هذه
الدراسات ، فوجئ الكثير منهم بالحصول على
تلك النتائج التي لم يعرفوها
ولكن مع مرور الوقت تعرف رياضيًا من النخبة
إذا كان
لديك انخفاض بنسبة خمسة إلى عشرة بالمائة  في
وظيفة أه الشاملة التي من الواضح أنها يمكن أن
تحدث فرقًا كبيرًا من حيث
قدرتك على اللعب في نفس المستوى